So now that you've sent requests to
a local host server, let's try seeing if
we can get information from other
servers out on the Internet.
Let's say I want to try to
access the API for SoundCloud,
an online audio distribution platform
that enables its users to upload,
record, promote and
share their originally created sounds.
In order to figure out what requests
I can send to the SoundCloud server I
will go to their developer website and
search through the documentation.
To control and
protect their resources, SoundCloud
requires developers to register
each application they want to create
that will communicate with their API.
Once my account is created, I'm
provided a Client ID and Client Secret.
I can embed these credentials into my
request in order to successfully access
the SoundCloud API.
Now, searching through
the documentation,
I see the resources that are available
for me to access, along with some
examples on how to create requests
to access this information.
Many of the post, put and delete methods
are protected with access tokens.
Since my app would need permission from
end users in order to post information
to SoundCloud on their behalf.
So for now I'm just going to build
a get request to view the contents of
a playlist with
the following playlist ID.
I must also add my client ID so
SoundCloud could
recognize that it's my application
trying to communicate with the server.
I can build the request using Curl or
Postman, send if off, and
see that I received
a successful response.
If I open the permalink URL provided in
the response, I can also see the HTML
page that contains this playlist
information in my browser.
In this next video, you'll be able
to delve into some APIs on your own.